i feel like it's been a minute i know
i've seen you i feel like it was season
one
since we talked last so now that we're
season three i mean what has this whole
experience been like for you oh my god
can you even put into words i can't and
i keep
trying to put it into words and then i
just start saying i can't put it into
words because it's inexpressible you
know it kind of lives in the
in the i've said this before i think i
said this at paley fest but it lives in
the utterable
you know what i mean it's it's just such
a blessing
yeah it really is i could cry and that
gets old
for me i cried so much yeah because like
secretly
if you don't stop crying you know um but
if i really think about it yeah
you know if you really step into it and
really think about it it makes you cry
yeah
and so you kind of have to be like you
know
um or you'll just always be in tears
yeah um have you taken out a role that
has made you feel
quite disempowered i feel like this is
such a a role that just brings a
different level
for entertainment it really does i i can
say that i
i've played i and i'm very great and
grateful for this uh because i do feel
like my path
has been sort of divinely laid out for
me yeah um
but i have had the privilege and honor
of playing a lot of empowered
uh characters or at least characters
that made me feel empowered
but this is on another level it would
seem that it that the scale
just continues to get bigger and so this
is by far the largest scale
or this has the the biggest reach and um
this has the longest uh sort of
um this is the longest legacy that i've
you know been a part of um i guess by
that i should say it's the only
legacy i've been a part of because this
is a multi-decade situation
so yeah in that way yeah i i this is the
biggest it's ever been
so when you find out that the show's
jumping 930 years into the future you
like
what i was like
yes yes i thought it was genius
yeah i thought it was a genius move
because we get to hold on to who we
already
are we already are where we're from
you know we're from 2256 and that'll
never change
we have the ties we have the connected
tissue to the cannon that we
have always had but now we're we're
somewhere where we've never been before
so it's it's boldly going where no one
has ever gone before
and being able to create canon every
choice you make
every step of the way there is something
so empowering
and emboldening and um humbling
about that so what can we expect from
michael season three
oh my goodness change change
um a lot of self-discovery
a lot of change you see some of that
change in the in in the trailer that we
released for comic-con
um a metamorphosis if you will and i
have to say that's the case for everyone
you know we sort of all saru had his
metamorphosis just before we jumped
right and so but we continue to see that
play out
and you know you see it with everyone
you see everyone
um stepping more into who they are
figuring out who they are everyone has
an experience everyone has a rough
transition actually into this future and
we
you know we don't spare anything you see
it you see how rough it is for everyone
and everyone is is sort of um
you know changing more and more into who
they're meant to be yeah okay well my
time's running out so i just have to
geek out for two seconds space jam two
i saw a movie in theaters i've been
waiting years for this how pumped are
you to be part of this phone so loved
i'm so grateful i never in a trillion
years would have imagined
because i loved space jam it was a yeah
as a kid too and i i
just can't believe it and it was such a
joy working with everyone um working
with with braun
and and um it it was just awesome no big
deal
i needed to just say brian yeah
james
that's where you're at now that's
amazing
i just love that you own that geek out
about that um okay so i have one more
minute left yeah
yeah almost wrapped up okay um so what
are you excited for the fans to see
um then when it comes to season three
are you just because
like you said this is can't like this
this people don't know what to expect
brand new yeah it's brand new we're
gonna they're gonna discover everything
with us
yeah you know what i mean we have to
because everything has to be discovered
right so
you know we couldn't have a better name
for our show right
um and and and what i love about it like
i said is that it's not easy it's not
you know sunshine and rainbows it it is
something that we have to fight for
and just what we what we're doing
in terms of special effects visual
effects um
every single department um just showed
up and showed out
and you will see things that will blow
your mind that you've never seen before
and what's it been like to be working
with jonathan frakes oh my gosh
this is the reaction i'm getting from
everybody they all kind of like melt
when i bring up his name
well he's just he's just so awesome he's
he's he's just obviously one of our
absolute favorite
directors ever you know we've got a
we've got a handful of them and he's
just
it's just a different it's a different
day when jonathan is there
you